nous avons eu la crise des urgences cet
été nous avons eu la crise de la
pédiatrie lors des épidémies de
bronchiolite maintenant nous avons une
crise des enfin une grève des médecins
généralistes on voit bien que le système
un peu part de tout côté et ce délite
alors que nous avions un bon système de
santé et puis il y a eu bien évidemment
la semaine passée les annonces du
président de la République qui qui part
un peu dans beaucoup de direction mais
sans beaucoup de clarté il faut bien le
dire je pense qu'il y a eu un temps
après la crise sanitaire le Ségur de la
santé et le gouvernement s'est senti un
peu pour solde de tout compte si je puis
dire en disant nous avons mis de
l'argent pour le Ségur pour la
revalorisation qui était plus un
rattrapage qu'une revalorisation mais en
faisant chaque semaine quasiment des
oubliés du Ségur ce qui est arrivé à me
contentement général on a en effet une
modification des aspirations le monde
des soignants avec des volontés de
concilier vie professionnelle et vie
familiale et plus les tensions sont
importantes plus les personnels manquent
dans les dans les services plus c'est
compliqué et difficile pour ceux qui
restent donc un en fait des personnels
en grande souffrance pour avoir fait la
commission d'enquête c'est ce qu'on a
des personnels soignants en grande
souffrance on l'a aussi dans le
médico-social et si on ne donne pas un
choc de confiance qui disent au
personnel nous avons pris la mesure des
difficultés voilà la feuille de route
elle ne sera pas forcément immédiate
pour certaines mesures mais qu'ils aient
un cap une visibilité c'est majeur parce
qu'on n'arrive pas à les faire aller
faire revenir dans les services
[Musique]